wurde der neunte planet in unserem
sonnensystem entdeckt und was gibt es
sonst noch daraus heute schauen wir in
das unbekannte dunkel des weltalls und
zwar direkt vor unserer haustür in
unserem sonnensystem wie viele planeten
gibt es eigentlich in unserem
sonnensystem 8 auf jeden fall
es waren mal 9 doch dann hat der
vermeintlich letzte planet der pluto
diesen status im jahr 2006 aberkannt
bekommen
schon vorher war lange darüber
diskutiert worden ob pluto wirklich
sowas wie ein planet ist oder doch eher
ein asteroid heute trägt er den status
eines zwerg neben ihm gibt es noch viele
andere objekte die mit ihm vergleichbar
sind und ebenfalls transnet tunnel sind
das bedeutet dass sie hinter dem letzten
gasplaneten neptun ihre bahnen in
unserem sonnensystem ziehen viele
objekte die so weit von der erde
entfernt sind existieren zum teil nur
hypothetisch durch verschiedene
berechnungen können wissenschaftler
davon ausgehen dass es dort planeten
artig oder zumindest große himmelskörper
gibt zum beispiel durch die mögliche
beeinflussung durch deren gravitation
auf andere planeten oder asteroiden
forscher vom california institute of
technology caltech haben nun
höchstwahrscheinlich einen neuen
planeten in unserem sonnensystem
entdeckt und der ist ziemlich groß er
trägt jetzt erst mal den namen planegg 9
die forscher gehen davon aus dass
planeten existieren muss da sich einige
objekte im kupfergürtel auffällig
verhalten was ihr bewegungsverhalten im
raum angeht
der körper gürtel ist eine region in der
sich auch der pluto befindet mit rund
70.000 objekten mit einem durchmesser
von mehr als 100 kilometern wie der ring
um den sektoren nur unendlich viel
größer muss man sich das vorstellen
es muss eine kraft geben die diese
objekte in kuiper gürtel beeinflusst was
konnten die wissenschaftler anhand einer
computersimulation feststellen
die größe des planeten soll zirka zehn
erdmassen entsprechen aufgrund seiner
entfernung zur sonne muss es sich um
einen eisplaneten handeln der für eine
umrundung der sonne zwischen 10 und 20
tausend jahren benötigt ja keine
gedanken schütze wir brauchen mit der
erde dafür
ein jahr es gibt allerdings auch
kritiker die nicht an die existenz des
planeten glauben sie gehen eher davon
aus dass es noch mehr zwergplaneten
geben könnte
die ebenfalls einfluss auf die
gravitation haben neben pluto gibt es ja
tatsächlich noch andere zwergplaneten
der unterschied zwischen einem planeten
und einem zwerg planeten besteht
übrigens darin dass zwergplaneten keine
bereinigten umlaufbahnen haben und dass
sie folgendermaßen aus die planetarische
diskriminierte gibt an wie groß das
massen verhältnis eines objekts zu den
objekten in seiner umgebung ist
ausgenommen und ein planet hat also alle
objekte in seiner nähe beseitigt bei
pluto sind für den status eines planeten
aber einfach zu viele andere objekte in
seiner nähe unterwegs das trifft auch
für andere objekte zu zum beispiel eres
der zwergplanet wurde 2003 von michael
braun entdeckt und das ist das zweit
massen reichste objekt nach pluto im
kupfergürtel michael braun was auch der
von der existenz von planeten ausgeht
und das diesen monat publik gemacht hat
objekte am rand des sonnensystems zu
entdecken ist extrem schwierig im jahr
2003 wurde sie mit hilfe von
weltraumteleskopen entdeckt das objekt
kann man vermutlich als zwergplanet
kategorisieren
2005 gelang es wieder unter der
mitarbeit von michael braun den
zwergplaneten make make zu entdecken er
hat einen ungefähren durchmesser von
1500 kilometern und braun geht davon aus
dass es noch mehr gibt zitat ich vermute
dass es mindestens ein wenn nicht sogar
mehrere bislang unbekannte objekte dort
draußen gibt was sagte er schon letztes
jahr in einem interview mit dem spiegel
70.000 objekte sollen sich ja im pulk
von gürtel befinden und das sind nur die
objekte mit mehr als 100 kilometern
durchmesser übrigens vermuten brown und
seine kollegen dass sich planet 9 vor
rund viereinhalb milliarden jahren viel
näher an der sonne befunden haben könnte
durch die gravitation der anderen
planeten soll er dann immer weiter an
den rand des sonnensystems gedrückt
worden sein
erhaltet ihr die existenz von planeten
für realistisch und nach welchem
römischen oder griechischen gott würdet
ihr ihn benennen den namen der am
meisten genannt wird den werden wir der
junior astronomie
international in paris vorschlag nicht
vergessen wenn es euch gefallen hat
daumen hoch für dieses video teilt es
auf facebook und twitter abonniert den
kanal ist er kostenlos und schaut das
nächste mit sicherheit spannende video
an
ansonsten bis dann bleibt ab